okay uh we're going to do just lay down
we're going to do headlock okay so
someone's got you like this any old way
just squeezing the the heck out of you
it's very
common okay so he's got you like this
and right now you're flat on your back
you want to try to get off your back you
see that yes sir so don't move him to do
that fit where there's Yin space face if
you can pull your elbow out he's not
holding it it might be stuck in his
abdomen torso leg just pull it out
you'll be able to turn even easier okay
and we'll go to frame first so he's not
cranking into
me okay you see I want some space so if
he's there I'll just get it in there use
that forearm bone on his hinge support
it with my other hand and just start
cutting into that
cored jaw hinge okay using the two hands
don't push them past the 90 just get
your elbow your upper arm extended it's
now in C you you can't push it can't
push it
okay you can if you need to you use this
hand you don't have those skills
whatever can also bring this hand on the
inside if there's room for it if he's
too wide for you to use this in any kind
of meaningful way
okay then start pushing this against
that jaw hinge to get him to lean back
enough for your
flexibility keep following the yin space
so see how I moved out from under him
I'm here don't push him into you you're
stopping him so keep creating Yin space
for him to fall back
into change to this point heel push him
under your leg now use your leg
strength so that your knees are on that
same area on his
neck control the arm take the bottom
leg cross the top
leg extend your legs your feet and your
spine away from each other and those
inner knee bones will crush and or choke
that neck jaw area do it
again follow the Y's face move where you
can inside of everything so if you he's
got me you can hear my voice talking as
I'm moving it's not going to change I'm
moving inside the in space every time
establish the C you on that arm you're
here drive into me it's never going to
do it but if you need to reinforce it
with the other hand move away so he
falls
push
up knees in place bottom
leg Over the Top This makes for more
crunch extend everything away your knees
will go
together causing great paining in the
jaw Andor go ahead and choke him out
okay let's try
it go
what do you think not going to it's not
going to
happen here that's it don't shove this
sir once you sh extend that hand then he
can use the long end of the lever yes
sir and un smashed again
I'm here I drive so let's say he's here
okay I drive to there you see that it's
not that I'm pushing him away I move out
of the way of his
body and now I move him into that space
do you see that yes sir haven't lost the
90 no sir then I take my palm heel he's
got less base now cuz he's not
here you see
then I hold the space I
created then my leg goes there then I
use legs straight on a compromised
person you see yes sir and I'm going to
keep the legs loose but my spine is
going this way my legs are going
[Music]
away so this is non- contestation is you
just it's not going to only because
you're stronger than me it's for when
you're not stronger than that person you
don't push on things okay try it again
I'm not even sure I could do that
mistake
okay here you in
space
establish move out of the way move him
into the empty space maintain the empty
space uh you uh if you open your grip
and you see my spine is more or less
straight I'm not like this hold
it anything think sir it's going to be
hard for me if I was flexible enough to
now open
this clanking my head in this
way so leave your head your spine as
straight as you can don't come in here
leave it here boom boom then this is
easy you didn't take away your
strength
okay try it
again okay same thing out on your side
don't let him keep you
flat move inside the space he's allowing
okay don't shove so same thing here
let's say he's close and I he's just
stronger than me I'm not going to try to
shove into that maybe I try a little bit
now it's not working follow the in space
come
out
over turn
keep your
GP turn
over St your
base get position first this isn't
hurting anymore squeeze it's not doing
anything okay establish your
base over stay inside this don't try to
pull on
it forearm get the same frame
this way
diagonally away from his
grip
control you can take top mount you can
get off you can ground and
pound and out try it
again move in the in space try nope
follow the in Space over start to climb
over
keep your
base all the way
over base clear position tight stay
inside his grip forarm in place just
like last time
legs to the
diagonal okay try it so let's say he's
got me here head look
when I'm here like this he he curls his
legs there's really no strength here
doesn't take much let's say that's all I
got okay cool I just hold it there and
go around this space you
see now here we
go if he's small enough I could be here
if not I go here okay I'm not trying to
overpower this grip
I'm trying to take his hands this
way not going here I'm going this way
you see how easy that is
okay I'm here this going to
hurt don't let me
out it's more crank in my neck okay so I
don't do that he's got it I turning his
hand this way okay yes
sir try it again you're not here to
overpower that person you're here to be
overpowered and still come out on top
okay go what's happening is your nonc
contestation is surface level or you who
don't train in this art it's just
non-existent so you try to overpower and
it just doesn't work okay it works if
you're bigger than them but I don't know
why a smaller person is going to attack
you and try to put you in a headlock and
if you're going in law enforcement it's
just stupid to think you're going to
overpower everyone it's
absolutely asinine okay you've been
training in non-c contestation but you
see you don't you don't and so now
contestation comes out and as a result
non-c contestation makes no sense to you
so you can't see it
okay
so here we
go okay so let's take this leg over hook
it use it to climb over
there you
go get in now is there anything in here
that's making me let go of my grip no no
so tap when you don't like it you see so
you're not out yet you have to turn me
all the way around okay here I am is
there anything letting making me let go
of my grip tap when you don't like it
you see you got to keep going
and turn me all the way around you're
trying to break it right now so go ahead
pull my arm no not going to happen so
why don't you turn my whole hips there
you
go do you have
base
no no so climb
again go all the
way all all the way to the other side of
my
body good stay inside there stop get
your base get your base you see cuz you
don't want me pulling you back right
okay now you do the next
move good pull it
tight little up a little up
there you go
on
good so don't expect them to just let go
there's nothing in there why you let go
and the person that puts you in a
headlock when they start feeling their
positioning becoming less dominant they
just squeeze Harder They Don't Let Go
okay try it again thank you
same thing move in the in space I'm
trying for it I can't get it I try to
climb he balls up you see same thing
follow the in space move around
[Music]
him establ
position
push
over out
side in the Y try NOP that would be a y
y Clash at that point I try to go it's
gone go around let him fall turn B
girl
position
leverage should be effortless try
it I try I'm not going to get it he's
too
strong I tried countered but now there's
all this space immediately right
there on him he's really big for me
maybe I get a l i can't get his arm
anymore so I went I stayed
here and I just make sure that as as I
move he's filling the
space go
back what I'm
doing is tilting him on his right
hip this
way okay if you can grab grab
lat
shoulder if you can't or you trap your
arms back here and you can't do it
you're going to just push onto that and
you keep filling the space as you're
creating
it rolling him on that inner hip
Bas okay make sure he fills the space as
you're creating it try it
again he's
down and we're at this cor he has the
headlock and I'm here we created space I
have established position
okay the whole point of this is so that
he can't crank me back the other way
okay try it I'm posting here with that
same C extension
go it's not going to happen Okay when
you're ready you're going to replace
this post with this leg you hold it in
position as long as
possible if your post goes this way
here's your front kazushi pattern right
here over your
go back you are
you have to
stay perpendicular to his
body so that this
foot is now your
post
go my weight's on that
side you
see there's too
much leverage
advantage and obstruction here this this
is where this
happens okay this
way this
way I'm sitting on this side and that
foot is replacing that post for that
roll okay sir you're not going to put it
here cuz it's not going to
work there's no support that way
supports this way you push that way you
don't push this way okay they try it
again clean it up attention to detail
you're only as good as your detail you
you and your your detail is only as good
as your eye if you can't see what I'm
doing you're going to the detail up
cuz your details up you suck
that's what happened try it
again okay on my side I trying can't get
it he's crying watchingg me cool go
around I try the hook okay he's in the
ball I pull as I move me I stay on my
side all right you're going to smell it
you see and you're going to want to do
this but he's very
strong if he puts his leg back I like
kissing hel you're not going you see you
guys get that so he feels himself going
back and you're let me do it first
I'm going to plop my hip and space and
you're going to try to do that you see
that this is what you're doing your hip
should not stay still if you go here and
you smell it and you try to go up and he
put his leg back and you back down where
you started you see that so what you
want to do is take it to where you feel
that urge okay that's all I can move now
I'm pushing on M and I move me so watch
my hip my hip is is going to move out
and start to
rotate now he falls and I go to my
knees
okay so your hip has to do a couple
things it is not a fulcrum here where
you can now go like
that it instead keeps going up the
circle and turns out the b bottom knees
come up you see
that it's not that the top
hip starts to come
over nor that it stays in place the
bottom hip and I start to try to come
up the bottom hip moves up the
circle and then pulls out the
bottom this way
now you're in the in space okay try it
again here is another fear response okay
this this is fear response this is fear
response move
in
try no move him back move him back pull
the bottom hip out he falls let go
you don't need this
anymore let go go to base
control you're still holding him here
because of your fear you're holding
him he's holding you to him there's no
need to grab him like this once he
crosses the point of no return there it
is you let go and get base
control got
it try